dylan cease makes his final start of
this season in the regular season with a
.95 against the tigers
this year
we appreciate them one and all dylan's
got a strikeout for you to start your
sunday one go on
castro with a liner to right and that
gets by a leaning laori garcia
harold castro into second base now he
turns it on he'll dig for three
the throw is late and harold castro has
himself a two out triple here in the
first looking right down and in look at
that bat you talk about being short
he took the short route right there
garcia just not a very
good play right here you got to try and
get in front of it play goalie
harold thought that he had it stopped
and he misplayed it so he on the third
probably be a double
fly ball deep right field back goes
garcia backpedaling his way misplays
that one too
castro trots home
haas hustling into second and rbi double
for eric haas he misses one and all of a
sudden here comes a tough one eric hoss
puts the charge into it he's got a
little tail unto it he doesn't play it
peek-a-boo on the wall there and uh rbi
double for eric haas
swinging a miss strike three and that
will be that goodram gave it up anyway
two strikeouts for seas tigers do get a
run we look at tyler alexander who's on
for his 15th start we saw him in detroit
the zra just under four and here's
robert the dh
that ball is annihilated
bring him home we're tied at one
it sounds like a musket
off luis roberts back he had a bad night
last night and he doesn't want to end
this season on a bad day
an absolute rocket our ford home run
replay
it was a no-doubter
he's driven in 43 he's now hit 13.
and you
just think back to what it would have
been had he had this
jazz cameron against dylan cease the o2
swung on and missed on a slider for
strike three he's got three punch outs
start of the day third in the american
league
this is a blue middle in fields got it
and hernandez puts away the final out of
the top of the second dinner menace
leads off for the white sox second
inning
this one lifted in foul territory daz
cameron nice sliding grab
good recovery it looked like he started
to glide on a little bit and drift on it
and then he
saw it at the end
coming up to the wall like that's tough
good catch good concentration
[Applause]
2-2 there goes the runner swinging a
miss thrown onto second is tall
and two gone as castro swipes second
base
goodrum slams this ball to center angle
has room though
and that'll do it
the 0-1
there's a little one hopper to short and
he totally botched it
and his throw was just late
he still had a chance to get tim
but the throw was tardy
that ball kind of had weird english on
it kind of a soft one hopper
20th pitch of the inning for tyler
alexander struck him out his first of
the day and he gets out of any damage in
the third we head to the fourth in a 1-1
ball game you're dylan cease this is
where you're going after that strikeout
fastball away got him for strike three
two down big strikeout for dylan he goes
to the heater keeps it in a perfect spot
just off the outside corner and throws
it by michael kopech comes into the ball
game for the 44th time
era three and a half lots of strikeouts
97 and 66.
badou
softly to left and in for a base hit his
first of the day there goes badou
pitches inside third on the second base
no chance that throw goes into center
field but do didn't see it and
he's quick he really gets a good joke
see that back knee
watch his back left knee
into the bag
infield is in
castro in the air to left
badou will tag
jimenez behind it he's got it here's the
throw home
way up the first base line tigers have
the 2-1 lead on harold castro's
sacrifice fly
there goes haas
and again again
2-1 tigers how about a new catcher a new
catcher zach collins with nobody out
strike three for kopeck
one gone
struck him out locked him up you gotta
make up your mind in a hurry with
michael kopeck out there because that
fastball not only is 98.99 miles an hour
but it just has so much late life
two and two
struck him out a dancing slider last
four outs for kobach and then strikeout
2-1 tigers bottom of the sixth inning
tyler alexander
pitched down and in
on the inside corner wow generous call
when kata didn't like it but it was at
the bottom
of the strike zone
one virus in the crowd didn't think so
tyler alexander will take it a strike
out of mankato for a team
jimenez gets rung up a couple of
strikeouts looking certainly did that
swing and a miss
flipped down to first to complete the
strikeout on the pitch in the dirt tyler
alexander strikes out three in the sixth
inning michael kopeck in his third
inning of work
2-2
is strike three
short didn't like it kopeck did
michael's fifth strikeout
three and two
that is strike three and everybody knew
it strikeout dispenser michael kopak
attacks again drew hutchinson comes in
the ball game so alexander's day is done
and he threw very well a run on four
hits
[Applause]
adam to left this could be two bases
let's see
haas gets there he's a catcher
adam engel the tying run at second base
andrew vaughn
through the right side
righty righty young andrew vaughn
has an rbi single to tie the ball game
that whole stroke was intended to take
the ball to the right side that's good
solid fundamental baseball
and it's a tie game
got to challenge him here on 3-2 he does
and grounded to first castro home to get
the lead runner
garneau dropped it but they did get him
anderson stuck in between home and third
tigers got him in a pickle
and he runs out of gas
and ryan toperan inning and now ronaldo
lopez he gets daz cameron to start
cameron to right field and deep back
goes garcia it's gone a solo homer to
lead off the ninth for daz cameron
and the tigers are back in front 3-2
fourth home run of the season for daz
cameron the second one of the season
against chicago
the one-noted guard no line by base hit
down the left-field line for these good
swings castro around second he will be
held at third now he's being waved
around third coming home anderson's
throat of the play not in time
late decision to send for ramon santiago
but it's up about belt high dustin
garneau pulls his hands in barrel to the
ball
and it was a late send and it was the
correct scent i think ramon santiago was
just sizing things up
knows the arms does his preparation
there goes zach short
badu sends one to left center field
jimenez is over he's got it that's deep
enough though to score dustin garneau
tigers now lead it 5-2 thanks to a kill
badou's sacrifice fly here's the two two
sheets
popped it up
this won't be easy to get to
and yet paredes makes a nice catch
he overran the third base coaches box
had to jump back
fell to the turf as he made the catch
hangs on for out number two boy he had a
long way to go
1-2
up the middle zach shorts got it and he
will step on the bag and the tigers
win the last game of the season 5-2
over the white sox worth a hug a high
five a smile and an embrace